welcome and thanks for taking out the
time for yourself for what will
hopefully be a nice inward journey
so just start off
sitting upright feet planted on the
ground if you're ideally on some type of
a firm chair
and start to
soften your gaze if your eyes are still
open
gently close them
i like to leave my hands on my lap
palms up to the sky but whatever feels
comfortable for you
and then with your eyes closed
gently become a little bit more aware of
your breaths
make them a little bit deeper
and a little bit slower
at your own time
breathe in
breathe out
just a little bit deeper
and a little bit slower
so the whole idea behind meditation
is
trying to ease all the chatter that
exists in our brains
trying to still our thoughts
and so as we do that in every meditation
i'm going to try to introduce some
frameworks ways of thinking about your
mind
but as you
try to quiet the mind it will inevitably
get distracted
it might get distracted by some noise in
the room or some noise outside
or more likely it'll get distracted by
thoughts that are just surfacing into
your consciousness and if that happens
don't let it make you anxious a lot of
folks when they meditate they worry that
they're doing it wrong and then if they
get distracted it actually makes things
worse they say i'm never going to be
able to do this meditation thing the
important thing is to approach the
meditation with a spirit of fun a spirit
of curiosity have a sense of humor about
it we are all literally human and we do
very human things and so when you find
your mind wandering a bit just laugh it
off and say oh there you go mind just
come back to the stillness not a big
deal don't beat up on yourself over it
and as part of that as we go through
this meditation as much as possible try
to keep a little bit of a smile on your
face
your eyes are closed but you can still
smile a little bit or at least smile
with your mind
reminds you that this should be fun this
is relaxing
so with that said
let's keep breathing in
breathing out
a little bit deeper
a little bit slower
and the framework that i'm going to
introduce for how you can still your
mind is one that i use a lot which is
imagining
all the thoughts in your subconscious as
the ocean
and the surface of the ocean is the
interface between your subconscious and
your consciousness
and most of us have a pretty choppy
surface there's a lot of thoughts that
are jumping up and down out of our
subconscious and sometimes we're
drowning in those thoughts
and one way to think about it is
we can elevate ourselves we can elevate
ourselves above the surface of that
water
and when you start to elevate yourself
you're not
suppressing the thoughts but you're just
looking down on them
you see that they're still there the
surface is still choppy there's still
waves but as you rise and you look down
on it you realize that you are not those
thoughts you are not the surface of the
water
so whether the thing that's bothering
you is an assignment you have to do or
some interpersonal relations
or just something in your life not
working out the way that you would like
it to
remind yourself that that is not you you
are not defined by the outcome of that
situation
those are just waves on that ocean
and the more that you surface above them
and you look at them and and analyze
them
you realize that they have no control
over you
and once that happens
things start to slow down the surface of
that water begins to get calmer and
calmer and calmer
and there you are floating above that
surface
just pure awareness
and you realize
that you're a lot more than you thought
you were
you aren't
just your physical body
you aren't just those thoughts that you
see as waves on the surface of that
ocean
you aren't even just that identity that
you associate yourself with your name
your position in the world your status
what people think of you your relations
those are aspects of you but they aren't
you
you are something much bigger than all
of them
you are the space in which they occur in
which they happen
but they aren't you and now let's just
try to sit in that pure awareness for
the next minute or so and once again if
your thoughts wander not a big deal
that's just the choppiness on the
surface of that water and you need to
elevate yourself back to that pure
awareness and if the quiet bothers you
don't worry i will be back in about a
minute
you
all right
so that was a relatively short amount of
time for you to be on your own and as
you'll see as we do more and more
advanced meditations give yourself more
and more time
and over time you won't need me talking
in fact that will probably annoy you
you'll just be able to sit down and
still your mind
and realize that you are not your
thoughts and these things that are
bothering you they're only going to
bother you as much as you let them
bother you
and the whole scheme of things
in all of time and space
none of them are really what should
define you
or are anywhere near as important as we
sometimes make them out to be
i'll see in the next meditation